[Musique]
l'art de survivre
dans une économie sans pitié
ces jours de troc ou de triché comme on
les appelle en Argentine et des kiosques
comme celui-ci à NC nada à une heure de
Buenos Aires il y en a maintenant des
centaines au pays
a apporté des vêtements qui ne vont plus
à sa fille
elle espère les échangés pour de l'huile
ou du sucre qu'elle n'a plus les moyens
d'acheter au supermarché
[Musique]
l'ordi troc l'argent est interdit
d'ygracial à l'organisatrice
inventée pour échanger leur bien
c'est comme ça qu'on se débrouille dans
un pays où l'inflation est chronique
comme un sortilège sans fin
2001 quand l'Argentine avait déclaré
faillite parce qu'on n'a pas d'argent
l'Argentine ne s'est jamais vraiment
remise mais les trocs avaient disparu
aujourd'hui ils sont plus populaires que
jamais et indispensables pour contrer la
hausse du coût de la vie une inflation
qui a dépassé les 100% en avril
travailler ne suffit plus les salaires
ne suivent pas
Andrea dit qu'elle vivait bien avant
comme infirmière pour des particuliers
ces jours-ci les patients ne peuvent lui
offrir que 300 pesos de leur c'est 1
dollar 50 le prix d'un café allez à
l'épicerie et même devenue un périple
des plus angoissants parce qu'on ne sait
jamais à quoi s'attendre
ça fait longtemps que la renoncé au bœuf
qui fait pourtant la fierté du peuple
argentin elle achète des saucisses et
encore chaque ami
depuis 24 heures le prix était de 200 et
là c'est 230 c'est comme ça tous les
jours c'est imprévisible les gens
peuvent pas planer
tous les 15 jours 10 Victoria la gérant
du marché local elle doit constamment
changer les étiquettes et surtout
dépanner les clients à la caisse son
carnet est rempli des dettes des
familles du quartier
des voisins sans le sou certains sans
toi littéralement juste en face de son
supermarché il y a une maison inachevée
on a commencé à la construire il y a
deux ans mais on a plus d'argent pour
installer la toiture la famille de 7 vit
dans cette petite annexe délabrée
l'aide sociale suffit à peine pour
nourrir les enfants il leur arrive de
sauter des repas
42% des Argentins vivent dans la
pauvreté
puis il y a ceux qui se démènent pour ne
pas y sombrer
Esther Adrian et Molina ont eu leur
talents pour mettre du pain sur la table
[Musique]
tous enseignent à l'Académie de danse et
de musique de Buenos Aires ils n'ont pas
l'habitude de travailler ensemble encore
moins dans la rue mais ils n'ont plus le
choix
le samedi et le dimanche au lieu de se
reposer ils font la tournée du quartier
historique de santelmo et passe le
chapeau
inflation pauvreté
trois mots pour décrire l'Argentine en
fois plus que l'an dernier
téléphone
si moi des élections présidentielles la
rue ne décolère pas comment l'Argentine
a pu en arriver là et peut-elle s'en
sortir
endetté le gouvernement dépense ou du
ses moyens toutes les politiques
budgétaires et monétaires ont échoué le
pesos des gringole au profit du dollar
américain qui est devenu la devise
refuge pour ceux évidemment qui ont les
moyens de s'en procurer
les rues du centre-ville de Buenos Aires
sont bourrés de changeurs illégaux qui
défie le tout et la limite établie par
le gouvernement
est un économie qu'il a fait de
l'inflation le sujet de son docteur il
prédit qu'à moins d'un plan draconien de
stabilisation l'économie ne s'en
remettra pas
l'inflation c'est un mode de vie ici
[Applaudissements]
on ne peut que compter sur nous-mêmes
diadrien seulement sur nous-mêmes
politique et le gouvernement ne font
aucun esprit
un pantalon pour du pain un coussin pour
de la farine ces femmes tiennent le coup
solidaires la tête haute résolue mais
pas encore